so now that biden's got all this
terrible news
joe biden is making a special appeal
to
the
establishment media to the big tech
companies that run the social media he's
saying look
i'm losing on capitol hill
i'm losing in the agencies please
please
shut down dissent
unfortunately while our military's
stepping up as they always do
there are others sitting on the
sidelines and we're standing in the way
if you haven't gotten vaccinated do it
personal choice
impacts us all
our hospitals our countries
i make a special appeal to social media
companies and media outlets please deal
with the misinformation and
disinformation that's on your shows
it has to stop
covet 19 is one of the most formidable
enemies america's ever faced
we've got to work together not against
each other
ann coulter pointed out yesterday she
said what is it called when the
government controls all of the
corporations and uses the ostensibly
private corporations to carry out the
will of the state is that what's that
something about a bundle of sticks i
does that starts with an f ends with an
ash ism i forget what do they call that
i forget
this is proof positive
of
two contentions that i've made on this
show for a long time that a lot of
conservatives have gotten
aware of in recent years one is that
liberals are the ruling class
they are the established power
they present themselves as the
opposition we're going to speak truth to
power we're going to fight the
patriarchy we're going to fight the
white supremacy we're going to fight the
conservative establishment but the
conservatives don't have any institution
in the country we don't control a single
one
talk radio is about as close as it gets
and and even that is regulated by the
administrative agencies which we don't
have
the liberals are the establishment
liberals run the government liberals run
the bureaucracy liberals run the
corporations liberals run the
universities liberals run the media
liberals run big tech liberals run
everything
the second contention that joe biden
just proved is that the journalists
by and large are fake news
because
the journalists
joe biden is speaking to these
journalists like good friends
it's different than when trump says
you're fake news i hate you you're scum
he would go to his rallies he'd say look
at those people back there look at those
press they're the scum of the earth
they're slime they're fake news
that was a very adversarial relationship
and the media started it what joe
biden's doing here is he's talking like
a friend he's saying hey guys come on
hey big tech ceos
hey
heads of the corporate press
you got to cool at letting these
conservatives on it's too much these
conservatives are really they're really
a thorn in my side
so come on guys
cool it with that i know i know that
you're already
extremely unfair to conservatives on
facebook and youtube and twitter i know
that you're extremely unfair to
conservatives in the corporate press you
got to be even more unfair
it's just because they're still getting
their message out and their message is
still resonating with the american
people and it's really hurting my
approval ratings so you got to stop it
you got to stop it
and even still even with
the entire power structure in this
country against us
even then
we
sometimes get
victories
got to ring that bell
that's that's how you're going to get
the notifications when the new videos
come out
probably the best way actually is you go
to apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts type in the michael knowles
show
subscribe
leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
you